وفي اول رد فعل منه على القصف الروسي الذي
تعرضت له
ومقاطعات الاخرى قال الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان الرئيس
يريد ان يحرق روسيا ومستقبلها وفق تعبيره
للشعب الروسي ان الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا هي تجسيد لرغبه شخص في البقاء في
السلطه
ولا اسباب تاريخيه لها انها استمرار لبقاء
شخص واحد في السلطه الى ما لا نهايه
كم عربه
ان يكون العام الجديد عام نصر لبلاده على
روسياف قال ان الهدف رئيسي الان هو
استعاده كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
القوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
في العام الجديد انه امنيه واحده توحد
جميع الاوكرانيين لتكون هذه السنه سنه
العوده عوده شعبنا وعوده الجنود الى
عائلتهم والسجناء الى منازلهم والمهجرين
ستعود الاراضي المحتله مؤقتا حره الى
الابد سنعيده ما سرق منا سنعيد طفوله
اطفالنا والشيخوخه الامنه لابائنا
وامهاتنا سيكون النجاح الاساسي لنا هو
التوحيد كل اراده اوكرانيا المستقله كما
كانت منذ عام 1991